you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is video 22
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and I'd like to share with you
an important trick and pawn endgame one
that ties in very well with the previous
video in the previous video we were
working with a seventh ranked pawn and I
demonstrated a very simple way to defend
against the seventh ranked pawn
maintaining file pressure when the King
is defending the pawn I suggested to
then start giving some checks and sure
enough there was just not a good way
forward for the stronger side a draw was
the result let us now consider upon that
is on the sixth rank everything else
being equal stronger sides rook in front
of the pawn defending rook behind
let us try now as the defending side to
take a similar approach as we did when
the pawn was on the seventh rank or in
other words let us try to maintain file
pressure to the sixth rank pawn now in
this video we are specifically concerned
with a sixth rank rook pawn okay
let's see king f3 rook a to king e4 rook
a 1 we're just going to bounce back and
forth with our rook keep in mind that if
the defending sides King tries to assist
tries to approach this pawn that won't
work
King f7 King e 7 this pawn can now dart
and as soon as he hits that 7th Frank
there should be six squares that light
up in your mind the significance of them
well if the defending sides King cannot
get to one of them fast and he cannot
that means the stronger side will be
able to win this was already shared in
our previous video he can try to get to
g7 but he's one move too short it's just
not going to cut it that's a skewer and
that's the ball game
therefore the stronger sides King was
stay put
King d5 King c6 king b6 he's defending
the pawn so let's now give a check rook
e1 King a7 aha the key difference
between a sixth rank pawn and a pawn
that is on the seventh ring there is now
a pocket for the stronger sides King
there is now not an ensuing file check
this difference matters
this means the stronger side will be
able to win let's see how rook b2 rook
b8 rook a to King b7 white is now making
progress the pawn is advancing one way
or the other the stronger side will be
able to slip out the checks will be
exhausted soon enough and the pond will
push through the stronger side will win
what did we just observe here we just
observed that applying file pressure to
the sixth-ranked
pond is not good enough now for the
longest time it was understood that this
rook and pawn endgame was a win until
Joseph van Kura came along
Josef van Kura was a Czech study
composer who passed away at a very young
age he was only 23 years old passing
away in 1921 and his contribution to
this rook and pawn endgame is to a chess
player invaluable his contribution his
work to this rook and pawn endgame was
published
three years after he passed away was
published in 1924 let us see what
exactly
Josef van Cora's contribution was to
this endgame what did he figure out King
f3 rook f1
kingi for
rook f6 this is the van Korra defense
with Joseph Vancouver figured out is
that the rook is best placed by applying
rank pressure to the sixth rank pawn now
why what is the difference file pressure
versus rank pressure well remember that
pocket for the stronger sides King that
is now not a safe haven for the king the
rook is able to in just a single move
challenge a king if he steps foot on a
seven and the reason for that is because
it is applying rank pressure it is just
a moment away from controlling that home
square that's safe square on a seven if
the rook is on a one that is not safe
ground for the stronger sides King let's
play out some moves here to get a feel
for Van Cora's idea this is a drawing
method King a five
rook b6 we want to maintain our rook on
the sixth rank we want to keep pressure
along a rank more specifically in this
position I want you to key in on these
five squares why am I not highlighting
the other two why am I not highlighting
g6 and h6 well that interferes with the
rooks ability to control seventh ranked
squares at least 7th ranked squares if
the rook is on g6 how do we ever get to
the seventh rank if we need to to give
some checks we can't the king is in the
way and similarly rook is on h6 sure we
could get to the seventh rank but what
good is it the King would be interfering
with the rooks ability to control the
seventh ranked squares therefore it
should really be these five that we key
in on at least in this specific case
rook b6 is perfect let's see what white
can try King d5 rook f6 King c5 we can
now there's some distance here between
the king and the rook we can now give
some rank checks this is what it's all
about it's about keeping rank pressure
on the pun or rank checks to the king
one way or the other one of the two you
want to always be doing one of those two
rook f5 King b6 rook f6 King a7 he's
trying to hide there but no we got that
covered we are using van Cora's idea we
give a check we can immediately question
that little pocket King be a crook f8
King b7 rook f7 king c6 rook f6 you get
the idea there are still a couple
nuances here some ways that we can go
wrong so let's still take this a step
further
King d5 we maintain pressure against
this pawn
King 'if I've rook c6 here's one way we
can go wrong if you play to f6 this King
has pressure against the rook and this
allows a little deflection tactic the
rooks are traded light goes on to win we
don't even want to put our rook in a
position where the King is putting
pressure on it even if we have defense
that defense can be rattled King
excuse me rook c6 therefore King d5
maintaining
ranked pressure we'll see some other
ideas Y can do soon enough with the rook
giving check and some other stuff like
that but for right now let's just run
with it king b5 let's give some more
checks rook check another check where's
the king going no progress being made
because our rook is functioning along
ranks we get now right back applying
rank pressure King e4
and what more to try not too much more
but here is one way to go wrong after
King D 4 you have to be extremely
careful now if you insert one more check
that is actually a loss maybe very
tempting to give this check
however after king to e5 we can now not
safely get back to this 6th rank
pressure rook f6 we've already seen this
little tactic will go on to lose
therefore we should immediately get
right back to this 6th rank to apply
pressure to the pawn
if you do go with this check and king e5
is played let's see what would happen
rook-a for this King can now move over
and get to this pocket there isn't a
good way to stop that what do you do
here king c6 rook a3 we've already seen
that this King will be able to hide in
that square so it's important at this
moment here you immediately get to that
sixth ranked using van Cora's defense
kingi five what more to try rook a7 okay
so as a general rule when this check is
on board we should stay clear of the
promotion rank King g6 will see an
example of how that could get us into
some trouble just as a general rule stay
off of that promotion rank rook a8 let's
get our King right back to that safe
Square one of the two safe squares King
g7 it's very important we do this if we
just make a waiting move with the rook
that's not good enough the rook well the
pawn can push right now and if we get
behind well our King is not on one of
those safe squares there's a check and
that pawn is pushing through so from
this point right here when the rook is
giving a check to the King we stay off
of this first rank King g6 if the rook
goes back to a8 we go right back to that
safe Square King g7 what more to try
King d5 rook f6 let's say the pond
finally something else's has to try
right you have to try something else
what to do now after the pawn has pushed
well this is now a seventh rank pawn and
what do we do to a seventh rank pawn we
apply file pressure rook a six
if we apply rank pressure that's no good
the rook can give a check and the pawn
can promote file pressure on on the
seventh file pressure pawn on the sixth
rank pressure what more to try King c5
we get some distance between the rook
and the pawn and we've already seen how
to draw this position now this
contribution he made to this rook and
pawn endgame it's pretty cool to see
this show up in games just a couple
years ago maybe even more current but
I'd like to share with you right now
a couple game couple top level games
where we get to see his idea used in a
game the first one I'd like to share
with you is between temor raja baath and
Hikaru Nakamura and this was from the
gash Ahmad memorial 2014 gash mob
memorial I'm just going to zip through
the opening and middle game of course
this is not of interest to us I have
included in the description to this
video the PGN the the moves to this game
if you'd like to check it out but yeah
we're just concerned with the endgame in
this one and we're going to get to see
how Nakamura as black uses puts into
practice here the vancour defense we are
almost there working with an a6 pawn in
this case the E and G pawns are now
exchanged and what do we have we have
the stronger sides rook in front of the
phone we have the defending rook behind
at this moment let's see how that
changes first Nakamura cuts off the King
King f4 what does Nakamura do next
he gets the King to one of those safe
squares King g7
and after King efore what to do next
rook b5 the rook is prepared to apply
rank pressure
rook check as a general rule stay off of
that promotion rank this is extremely
important the move here that Nakamura
played is king g6 if the King goes to
the first rank in this specific case it
is now a loss let's quickly see why the
rook can play to c7 the rook can get
behind the pawn but after a7 how are you
stopping check and then promotion you
can't not a good way and it's because
the King was on that promotion rank so
in case you're checked in this position
it's best to step up it's best to stay
off of that promotion rank to avoid
scenarios like that King d4 rook b6
kingi 5 rooks e6 maintaining rank
pressure Van Cora's idea in practice in
action after rook to a8 we get right
back to that safe square on g7 and at
this point raja baath realized nakamura
demonstrated he knew Van Cora's defense
he knew how to draw the position and so
allows the pawn to be captured in the
rooks to be traded a draw on board one
last example and this comes from a game
between our current world champion
Magnus Carlsen and Levon Aronian this
was another 2004 game from the
Sinquefield Cup once again just zipping
through the opening and middle game the
endgame is what's of interest to us here
and I have included the game notation to
this one in the description as well you
may recall from
the previous video in this playlist
I added some new features I added some
more elements to the position I added
some pawns in other words and I showed
that even with some more pawns involved
we can still have a draw on board we get
to see this very thing happen in this
unique endgame Aronian again playing as
black here you ready rook b3 the start
of a transfer of the rook here the rook
is transferring to a spot where he can
now apply rank pressure we're not quite
working with a sixth ranked pawn but
still the same idea is present in this
endgame the pawn is on a5 we can still
put we can still use this same method we
can still use van Korres idea King c2
rook b5 King takes pawn Carlson is up
three pawns here but this is a dead drop
using Van Cora's defense rook f5 rook a8
let's see what is tried in this endgame
key idea maintain rook pressure rank
pressure
checks to the king or pressure against
the pawn one or the other and what more
to try let's see what Carlson tries in
this one a little zigzagging along the
seventh and eighth ranks there
maintaining rank pressure one pond is
scooped up an insignificant one
something just happened there something
very important this pond just advanced
it's now a sixth ranked pond and a big
moment for Aronian file pressure or rank
pressure rank pressure it is King g8
rook b8 king f7 Rick b6 what more to do
maintaining rank pressure is the key
idea and there is just not a good way
forward no good progress even though
light was up three pawns and eventually
interestingly enough we see something
similar happen in this game just as
Timur Raja Bob did against Nakamura
eventually realizing okay black
demonstrated the drawing method here
let's just go ahead and allow the pawn
to be captured in the rooks to be traded
and it to be stripped down to just king
versus King what more would there be to
try here if rook e8 we would get to one
of these safe squares if the pawn pushes
we get right behind the pond and put
file pressure on it because it's a
seventh rank pawn and we have already
seen I've already shared in the previous
video this type of an endgame you can
have this extra pawn here but it still
is not going to work it can be a knight
pawn it can be a rook pawn but that
still is not going to be enough this
will also be a drop we've already seen
this so it's pretty cool to see that you
know a guy's idea from 9th Earl II 1920s
is you know still still used in the game
today pretty cool stuff
anyhow that's all I have for you right
now in this video feel free to leave any
feedback
in the comments section below and I will
catch you in the next one that's all for
now
take care bye
you